I'm about to show you incredible
examples of ruins from lost ancient
civilizations that are now somehow under
the ocean but what is stranger than
finding lost ancient cities underwater
is the fact that there are so many
different examples of them and
throughout almost every corner of the
Earth's oceans I mean whether it's ruins
from a lost ancient Egyptian city that
was discovered under what is now the
Mediterranean Sea made up of massive
statues and stone boxes that were cut
with remarkable precision as well as
stone columns and many other things
including even that of a Sphinx have all
been found at this impressive site but
why on earth is this ancient Egyptian
city now 25 feet under the ocean and as
far away as seven kilometers or four and
a half miles from the modern-day
coastline of Egypt that's further out
than the eye can see as the average
person's ocean horizon from the beach is
barely over three miles or five
kilometres away this site is located off
the coast of Alexandria and was once the
ancient port city of her a Cleon but is
now an archaeological treasure trove of
artifacts and stone structures that
continues to be excavated to this day
surveys have revealed 2,500 pieces of
stonework and 70 large monolithic blocks
as well as an obelisk and many broken
stone columns and pillars as well now
the Mediterranean Sea itself has to be
the jackpot for lost ancient underwater
ruins as they've been discovered in so
many places throughout this entire
region from off the coastlines of Greece
senate's islands to the coast of Italy
and other islands throughout the sea
including Sicily creats Malta and others
that are scattered throughout the region
the ocean battered remains of structures
consisting of large cut and stacked
stone blocks but now we can only imagine
what places like this look like before
they were consumed and tattered by the
sea in fact here you can see the added
CGI to the crumbled remains of a
structure off the island of Crete that
paints us a picture and reminds us that
these structures once had walls and a
roof there are also many different
statues that have
found in places throughout the
Mediterranean that were once within
courtyards entrances to businesses and
even inside the living rooms of homes
and palaces the leftover stone dividers
that made up courtyards - even the
submerged resting place of a bathhouse
which included extravagant solid stone
bathtubs for people once bathed within
the privacy of their cozy estates even
the preserved remains of a tall stone
archway leading through a wall that once
led to who knows where but perhaps a
place or path of significance at one
point in time and I have to say that I
find images like this one to be so
thought-provoking
the incredible architecture and design
of artistic tile flooring that was once
within the lobby of a building or
perhaps the living room or foyer of some
rich ancient person's villa something
tells me that none of the people who
once walked upon these various places
had any idea that where they were
standing would one day be hidden beneath
the waves of the ocean the eerie remains
of what were once streets and walking
paths - even the solidified tracks of
ancient cart ruts that formed a path for
people once traded and traveled through
every day of their lives
of course not knowing that it would all
be submerged among fish and coral reefs
for thousands of years until us there
are future ancestors would one day come
along with our inconceivably more
advanced technology including cameras
sonar equipment motorized boats
submersibles and even our simple yet
highly sophisticated scuba equipment and
here we are now viewing these sites on
YouTube from our phones and computers
that are connected to our invisible
Wi-Fi
what's an amazing time to be alive to
see this stuff and I wasn't kidding when
I said that these underwater sites are
all over the place and so far I've only
shared a few of the places scattered
throughout the Mediterranean which I'll
be coming back to in a moment to share
and discuss more of but some of the
deepest underwater ruins that have been
discovered are found all the way over
off the coast of India within the Gulf
of Cambay these ancient ruins include
cut and stacked stone blocks and other
relics some in the shallows but many of
which were hidden deep under the waves
of the ocean for
several thousand years in fact possibly
more than nine thousand years which if
true would raise many more questions
than we already have about this
mysterious site but one thing that makes
it so incredible is that these ruins
have been found as far away as twelve
and a half miles or 20 kilometers from
what is now the modern-day coastline of
India and get this at depths of 40
meters which is 131 feet deep
how and why some consider this to be
remnants of the ancient civilization of
derocker which according to legend is
the hometown of Lord Krishna a place
that many believed to be just a myth
that was until these ruins were
discovered 131 feet below the surface
which of course baffled the so-called
experts that said it never existed in
the first place however it's still the
subject of debate and uncertainty and
needs further study but regardless of
who once lived there and when it's still
12 and a half miles from the coast in
other words this site is four times
further the distance than the average
person's ocean horizon from the beach
and not only that it's more than 100
feet deeper than the submerged Egyptian
city I just showed you moments ago even
as we go to the other side of the world
to the shadow waters off of the Bahamas
there is a site commonly referred to as
Bimini Road off of Bimini Island look at
these photos and think for yourself this
potential ancient road is now 18 feet or
five and a half meters below the surface
which is shallow enough to freedive this
linear path is a half mile or point
eight kilometers in length and consists
of three predominant sizes of blocks
some as small as 1 to 2 metres or 3 to 7
feet in width many others are 10 feet
and the largest grouping of stones are
13 feet or 4 meters wide this so-called
Road is of course the subject of debates
however I suspect that it is indeed the
remnants of a lost civilization that
existed thousands of years ago when much
of the Caribbean was actually land if
these are indeed ancient remnants then I
can only imagine what else is waiting to
be found below the shallow blue water
that cover large sand flats throughout
the Caribbean what could be laying just
feet below the sandy bottom but speaking
of a debated site something located not
far away is the so-called Cuban
underwater city or pyramids at the dark
depths of nearly 2500 feet deep or 750
meters down on the ocean floor and off
the west coast of Cuba this made
headlines around the world upon its
initial discovery in 2001 but has been
seemingly forgotten in the media ever
since
do these sonar images actually depict
man-made structures and if so how did
they get this deep while staying intact
enough to be identified and if these are
ancient ruins how old would they have to
be and could they be in any way
connected or related to the pyramids
found not far away in Mesoamerica but
what you need to know is that this image
here was created from this sonar image
here this animated rendition was created
on someone's interpretation and may not
necessarily be accurate to its true form
what we do know is the last study of
this place at least that is known
publicly was back in 2001 the
researchers visited this site twice the
first time when their sonar image was
taken the second when they lowered a
submersible down to capture photos and
apparently these were the best pictures
taken which they claimed could be of cut
stone blocks that are some eight feet
long but really it's hard to tell
anything from these blurred photos it's
also worth mentioning that the same
people that found this site acknowledged
that it may not be man-made at all and
that it needs to be studied further
they're not trying to convince anyone
that it's a pyramid or that this site
contains cut stone blocks I mean I
certainly can't tell anything from these
images and I don't find the comparison
of the sonar image to the animated one
to be similar at all but then again so
do our imagery is not something that
I've ever studied or learned but it is
nearly 20/20 so really we are overdue
for someone to obtain new high-quality
camera footage or pictures for
additional examination definitely leave
a comment and share what you think about
this site and
any other details of it than you may be
aware of but that aside let me take you
to the other side of the world to what
has to be the most highly debated
underwater site on earth known today as
the Yonaguni pyramid or monument which
is right off the beach of the Japanese
island of Yonaguni which by the way is
actually closer to Taiwan than it is to
Japan but this structure consists of
incredible formations that boggle the
mind with wonder as to what's possible
is it natural or is it man-made and if
so how could it be possible when it
reaches depths of 26 meters or 85 feet
at its base and five meters or sixteen
feet from the top of the structure from
the surface creating the big question
which is is this a nearly ten thousand
year old man-made structure that was
later consumed by rising sea levels or
simply a freaking amelie shaped by
strong and unusual tidal forces within
its vicinity the first time you see
these captivating images it's hard to
think even for a second that this could
be 100% natural I mean look at those
edges look at all the different forms
and shapes of the rock that seemed just
too odd to be solely a natural
phenomenon some even suggest that there
is an eroded face carved into a lower
corner of the rock and some suggests
that there is an archway made of cut and
stacked blocks also located on the lower
part of the formation as well
puzzling details and images like this
really make you wonder how this could be
totally natural the first time I saw
this I thought that there is no way that
this could be totally environmental not
for a second why well because just look
at it since when does nature create
straight edges and angles at least to
this size and scale I mean why haven't
we seen other natural examples
comparable to this one elsewhere around
the world however many experts who I do
respect including dr. Robert Schoch who
is a geologist at Boston University has
studied this site in person and now
argues that it is indeed natural he even
points out that the apparent right
angles are not perfect at all when
inspected more closely I have to say
that he does make a very persuasive
of argument that certainly made me doubt
the possibility of this being a man-made
formation although I am open-minded to
further study and I'm not ready to
completely dismiss the sites but I do
have doubts however when I see images
like this one I have to ask how did a
strong current create this unique shape
and with the center incision in the
middle how'd the current do that in this
specific area where there is no apparent
rock or land feature blocking the ocean
currents thus providing the unique
feature that we see now even look at
this incision which is only several
inches wide so no those are not steps
running down the terrace on the
structure how did the current which is
of course coming from the side of the
structure create this on the top and why
don't I see other examples of this
occurring naturally around the world is
it possible that this is a combination
of both perhaps in long-lost ancient
structure that was consumed by the ocean
in an area that has very strong and
unusual tidal currents definitely leave
a comment and share what your thoughts
are on this one because this is
complicated do you think it's man-made
do you think it's natural or could be a
combination of both I'm very eager to
read and see what people have to say
about this one but Yonaguni aside and
going back to my point that ancient
underwater ruins are all over let me
continue around the world this time to
the Indian Ocean and the island of Sri
Lanka located at the southern tip of
India the submerged consoie Rama temple
at Swami Rock was discovered in 1956 by
archeologists while scuba diving at
depths of 50 feet or 15 metres the site
today is highly protected which is
probably why it's hard to find great
photos of it however you can still see
remains of stone blocks structures and
many different Hindu statues that now
lay on the ocean floor including this
creepy looking head the leftovers of a
bust or statue just imagine if you were
snorkeling in the ocean and randomly
came across this thing now it must be
mentioned that much of this sank only a
few hundred years ago but one thing
that's interesting is that other parts
of it may be much older and could
potentially corroborate ancient Indian
tales of a land bridge that once
connected mainly in India to Sri Lanka
that would not surprise him
as satellite images from NASA seem to
corroborate it but as we continue
elsewhere around the world all the way
over to Micronesia which is located in
the remote South Pacific Ocean you can
find the ancient and in many ways
mysterious relics of nan madol
where much of this lost civilization has
been swallowed into the shallows what we
see today is simply far different than
this engineering marvel would have
looked during this civilizations height
so long ago as they use great ingenuity
and utilizing these volcanic stones for
their structures and of course not
knowing that ocean levels would one day
rise and consume their way of life
leaving behind mystery the question
becomes just how quickly did this happen
however you can see what the ocean does
to ancient constructions leaving behind
nothing more than an unrecognizable heap
of broken stones that slowly break down
to sand leaving behind mystery and
further questions about lost ancient
civilizations and the remote islands of
the Pacific and perhaps nothing is more
remote than Easter Island which of
course has the mysterious moai statues
it's always fun sharing images like this
one as most people have no idea just how
massive some of these statues actually
are however one image that most people
have never seen before is this shocking
image of a massive moai statue that is
laying on the ocean floor with marine
life now growing on it when I first saw
this I couldn't understand how I've
never seen or heard of this inexplicable
underwater statue before which of course
could have significant implications to
the details that historians thought they
knew about the moai statues particularly
their age but unfortunately that
excitement was good for barely 10
seconds as my immediate Google search
quickly informed me that this is simply
an artificial statue that was a movie
prop for some no-name film in the late
1990s bummer but that's how things go on
the internet there are fake things that
some try to pass off as real or
otherwise exaggerated whether it's in
various email forwards or social media
posts not everything you see is real in
fact let me clarify that these images
here are not real and no those are not
underwater columns and
this pyramid is not actually under the
ocean it's simply CGI but unfortunately
not everyone is aware of that when they
see these types of photos make their way
across the internet and that reminds me
if we go to Indonesia and the beautiful
waters off of Bali you'll find a
submerged temple consisting of Buddhist
statues and other relics all of which
are not actually ancient ruins at all
but rather an artificial coral garden
that was placed there to facilitate the
growth of coral reefs and generate
tourism through the creation of a
popular new dive spot same for the
nearby Indonesian island of gili meno
where you'll find another coral garden
but this time consisting of 48
life-sized statues situated in a circle
all of which were cast from real people
some have referred to them as hauntingly
beautiful my first impression of this
site was yeah it's a little bit creepy
but never mind that as I love the idea
of creating coral gardens around the
world but one thing I do wonder about -
regarding lost civilizations in the
Pacific Ocean is that there are
different legends describing a continent
that once existed throughout a large
area of the Pacific and satellite
Islands existing today such as Easter
Island Hawaii Fiji and the Samoas to
name a few are essentially all that's
left of this now submerged continent
could there be any truth to this legend
this will be a topic I revisit in a
future video along with the legend of
the lost city of Atlantis that was said
to collapse beneath the waves
but movie props CGI photos artificial
coral gardens and legends of sunken
continents aside do you want to hear of
a place in a country that may surprise
you that has ancient ruins underwater
from the largest ancient Greek city to
ever have existed Russia that's right
however let's not forget that Russia is
massive and I'm not referring to its
specific coast but rather the sea of
azov which of course was once part of
the Mediterranean Sea as a whole
although its waters do still technically
connect to it this is the location of
phanagoria on the Tumen peninsula which
like I just mentioned was the largest
ancient Greek city to ever exist leave a
comment if you've never heard of this
place before or realise that it is now
some
in Russian waters and beaches but even
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
dived this large and impressive site and
here you can see different images of
relics that have been found so far and
you can also see other aspects of this
lost city that are now buried and being
excavated along the shorelines this is a
very interesting site and who knows
what's waiting to be found as exavation
still continued to this day and it's a
very large area but you see I wasn't
joking when I said that the
Mediterranean has to be the jackpot for
lost ancient underwater ruins whether
it's lost ruins and the shallows off of
Spain near the coastal city of Seville
or on the other side of the
Mediterranean off the coast of Turkey in
the island of Ko Cova this lost ancient
Aleutian settlement was partly overtaken
by the sea due to an earthquake nearly
two thousand years ago and you can still
see the remains of a Byzantine Basilica
just 20 meters from the shore and 2
meters below the surface essentially
what was once the middle of the city is
now the coastline and going south of
Turkey off the coast of Israel you'll
find ancient ruins that date back some
8500 years making the site of outlet
Yama extremely old for even the ancients
these ruins range between 8 to 12 meters
or 25 to 40 feet under the sea and
underwater excavations have uncovered
artifacts and structures and include
rectangular houses and even well what's
crazy is that they believe that this was
destroyed suddenly likely due to a ten
story tall tsunami which was potentially
130 feet high that followed the collapse
of Mount Etna some 8,500 years ago just
imagine that even going back to the
coast of North Africa and west of Egypt
Tunisia has remains of incredibly large
monoliths the submerged remains of the
Roman Neapolis which spans an area of 50
acres an underwater expedition has found
streets and monuments yet little is
known about this ancient site but the
point is that something very impressive
was once happening here as these blocks
are massive and potentially pre-roman
but if we go to a more remote area north
of Tunisia there is a massive stone
column laying one
thirty feet down on the sea floor in the
Sicilian channel between Tunisia and
Sicily what's nuts is that researchers
believe that it was submerged
approximately ninety three hundred years
ago at a time when sea levels were much
lower and by the way this is the same
depth and time frame as the ruins in the
Gulf of Cambay off India's coast that I
shared earlier I find the similar
timeframe and depth below the surface
interesting this 15 ton limestone pillar
consists of drilled holes as you can
still see today the monolith is 12
metres or 39 feet long and is better
appreciated in comparison to people
scuba diving near it the remote nature
of this find should raise questions to
everyone especially since this thing is
on the sea bank 60 kilometres or 37
miles south of Sicily I mean really what
is this thing doing here and if you
think that's strange and mysterious then
we remind you of a recent study on the
Persian Gulf that I shared in a prior
video this study states that it is
incredibly likely that a large ancient
civilization lies buried beneath the
Persian Gulf today which is crazy
considering it is 290 feet deep under
the ocean today they say it was above
land for 100 thousand years before being
fully submerged around 8,000 years ago
and these pictures are of people scuba
diving in the Persian Gulf
but unrelated to anything involving
archaeology but I'm showing you this to
get you thinking of what could be laying
just meters beneath the Persian Gulf
sandy bottom and this ties in to the
point of this video which is essentially
a continuation for my two previous
videos which heavily outlined the fact
that lost ancient civilizations are all
over and in far more places than we
thought possible from the entire Mideast
to the Sahara Desert new discoveries are
occurring more and more frequently and
in places that continue to surprise us
go watch those two prior videos and when
combined with this one you'll certainly
be surprised at how much we don't know
about our ancient past and how much is
waiting to be discovered because mark my
words this is just the beginning of
what's waiting to be found within our
lifetimes and the ocean is a whole other
frontier I mean let's remind ourselves
of the awkward fact that we hardly know
anything about our own ocean
even Noah will tell you and I quote that
more than 80% of our ocean is unmapped
unobserved and unexplored hell we
haven't even found mh370 that massive
Boeing triple7 commercial airliner that
disappeared closer to 6 years ago now
I've used this example before as it
makes an interesting point in that we
know what it is and we are actively
looking for it but still haven't found
it
whereas lost ruins hidden now under the
ocean are simply not being searched for
like at all and here's something that
will get you thinking in 2004 a large
ancient forest was discovered 60 feet
underwater off the coast of Alabama and
what is now the Gulf of Mexico and has
been completely submerged for tens of
thousands of years following rising
ocean levels at the end of the last ice
age but what's crazy is it wasn't even
known to exist until 2004 following the
wake of Hurricane Ivan from the year
prior which moved enormous amounts of
ocean floor sediments and exposed the
remains of this ancient forest and get
this it was discovered on accident by a
fisherman perhaps we should start
studying the ocean floor following
powerful storms because who knows what
is constantly being exposed in one place
and buried in another so the big
question many of you probably have right
now is how and why are there so many
different ancient ruins found under the
ocean well several major underwater
sites in the Mediterranean are the
results of earthquakes and tsunamis
however ocean sea levels have been
rising for tens of thousands of years
and have played the largest role in the
depths that these sites are now at for
example look at this graph of historical
sea level rise and you'll see that at
the height of the last ice age
approximately 21,000 years ago the
oceans sea levels were approximately 425
feet or 130 meters lower than they are
today think about that and then notice
the sharp increase around 12,000 years
ago which is the results of the Younger
Dryas climate catastrophe that I have
cited in many past videos and also note
the steady rise in sea levels over the
past several thousand years since now
look at this graph that goes back 450
thousand years and shows that there have
been five interglacial periods
essentially sudden bursts of warming
that followed much colder temperatures
that facilitate the growth of glaciers
and change the climate and weather
systems throughout the world it almost
seems to occur on a fairly regular
occurrence as if the earth is actually a
cold place far more than it is a warm
one at least in comparison to today's
climate like I always say in my videos
research this stuff on your own and
think for yourself but what the data I
just mentioned particularly the ancient
shorelines being now more than four
hundred feet lower than they are today
this can help us to discover more
submerge ruins as we should be searching
within the boundaries of known ancient
shorelines
you see that's how there are ruins
twelve and a half miles off the coast of
India and one hundred and thirty feet
deep the ancients had coastlines that
were vastly different than ours are
today this should get us all thinking
next time you're at the beach and
looking out into the ocean you may find
yourself wondering what lies out there
past the horizon under the ocean what's
waiting to be found are there ancient
ruins out there you may find yourself
turning to the person next to you and
being like so I saw this YouTube video
with this guy named Jimmy that told me
but anyways this is getting a bit long
but definitely leave a comment and share
any other sites that I didn't include in
this video because there are quite a few
in fact my original goal when making
this video was to find every possible
site and give all the details about them
until I realized that it was gonna be
like a 2-hour video which some of you
might want but it wasn't gonna be very
boring and just way too much so I'm
gonna have to revisit this topic in
another video so leave a comment and
share any other sites that I didn't
include in this one and share any other
details about these sites that I did
share that I didn't include in this
video but anyways guys hit the like
button subscribe leave a comment but I'm
Jimmy my channel is called bright
insight and I have another video coming
for you very soon take care everybody